from small-scale car thieves in LA to
million-dollar bank robbers in Rio it's
fair to say the scale of the Fast and
the Furious films has grown over the
years now it looks like the franchise
has earned its own spin-off movies - I'm
Simon and this is your entertainment
news updates the eighth movie in the
Fast & Furious series is now in
production and there are already two
further films shedding for release over
the next few years we may also get some
spin-offs from the hit action series
star Vin Diesel has previously spoken of
his desire to make other films set in
the same universe
and now producer Hyrum Garcia has
revealed that a movie focusing on Dwayne
Johnson's character Hobbs is under
discussion in an interview with comic
book calm Garcia said that a movie about
the muscle-bound FBI agent was something
that both him and Johnson were keen to
make I think there's always been
conversations for that the shedding of
it all is a challenge but there are
always talks about a potential spin-off
movie and what we can do with it
DJ and I were just talking about that
the other day our visions for it
he's a beloved enough character that
they'd love to see what a ride with him
would be like in his world we have tons
of history that we've crafted for this
guy that we continue to sprinkle in
throughout the movies you'll see a
little bit more in this movie but
ultimately we want to take that ride and
spin him off and have some fun with it
in February diesel announced the release
dates for the next three parts in the
faster viewer series with part 8
arriving in 2017 and the others
following in 2019 and 2020 one last week
the first image of Charlize Thorens Fast
& Furious 8 character was released the
ROM will play a character called cypher
who Universal claimed to be the
franchise's greatest adversary ever the
movie hits cinemas on April 14th 2017
does the idea of a solo Dwayne Johnson
lead Fast and the Furious movie rock you
or should the people give this one the
elbow let me know in the comments or
come find me on Twitter I'm at the
jaegun or thanks for watching and for
your entertainment news keep it GameSpot